oh boy
we've got new headphones in these are
the new sony link buds i'm really
excited to test these out because i did
like a little briefing before i actually
got hands-on with them and the thing
that i'm most excited about every other
kind of like headphones that have been
coming out recently i feel like there's
been no change to them they all have
sort of the same look the same kind of
design this even goes for airpods like
it's kind of technically the same but
what sony has done kind of interesting
so i'm really excited to open these up
and test them out so this actually came
in a really cool media kit and it was
this awesome augmented reality
experience um
you guys want to see what that looked
like check out my friend farooq he did a
really cool unboxing and demo of it mine
unfortunately is at my parents house on
the east coast and it was a really heavy
box and there was no way that i was able
to fit it into my luggage but i did get
a chance to open it there so i brought
back the tiny box which actually
contains our link buds now i'm excited
about this because these have basically
been re-engineered from the ground up to
give you kind of this new listening
experience and you'll see
why this is different when we get in
here
how small this is wow this is a really
tiny little case here they are
it's also extremely light like i don't
know
if in comparison to air pods it i think
it feels lighter okay what else do we
have in the box looks like we have a usb
cable
usbc there's our charging port and
here's the sizing rings to make sure you
have a perfect fit when you put them in
your ear so something else
oh
some documentation
a lot of documentation just gonna
put the documents here we're gonna file
those away for later
so here we've got we've got the goods so
these will give you about five and a
half hours of battery life on a single
charge but if you do use the charging
case it'll give you an additional 12
hours for a total of 17 and a half hours
i kind of judge headphones is like can i
wear these from the west coast to the
east coast on a single flight and
yeah i could even if there's a layover
by the time i would have the layover i
would have them in the case they would
already be charged up for the next
flight so they do pass the time test
so what makes these kind of different is
this kind of new design they have like
this open ear system they've got these
holes that are uniquely placed so that
you can actually hear the surrounding
world around you and this is something i
actually really like and it's one of the
reasons that i still use the original
version of the air pods i feel like
there really hasn't been this big
overall redesign of earbuds they all
have that same similar look sony has a
ton of really great high quality in-ear
headphones and they sound absolutely
awesome and i've reviewed them in the
past i love them i still use them i also
love their over-the-ear headphones and
something else that i thought was kind
of interesting is if you guys are fans
of sony audio you guys will know that
they have some wild names for a lot of
their headphones like they've got things
like the sony wx1000xm3
and it doesn't seem like it's a very
consumer-facing
kind of name if you're like hey yeah
check out those 456 324wx
abcdefg whatever headphones this is
different they've renamed them to link
buds and there's two colors there's also
like a darker kind of gray color and
these are like a very very light gray
kind of like an almost white here's what
the back looks like and so this part
kind of stays into your open ear and
this
just kind of nudges itself into the
crook of your ear canal ear canal is it
here i don't
my ear uh facts
not sure and i like that they wait left
and right i always get my left and
rights confused as well we'll see how
this is gonna fit oh okay all right i
like this a lot interesting
feels like it's in there pretty good
this is the medium
i'm smiling and they're not falling out
and i'm moving my head around wow okay
this is a great first test see here's
the little rings oh boy all right
there's a lot of those these look like
little spider eggs or something i have
mixed them up so now i'm unsure of
sizing but i feel like i
could match them up and figure it out
because i am an intelligent person
looks like these are the small this is
probably the extra large and those are
the large and the medium is here and to
switch the sizing you just kind of take
the ring
right off just like that it's very very
simple i think the medium was probably
pretty good but you don't know unless
you try so it just wraps right around
the edge of the headphones okay i think
i might need the medium the medium was
perfect why did i try to fix perfection
here's the case this case only charges
with usbc here of course we have our
bluetooth pairing this case isn't
wirelessly chargeable so you can't put
this on a wireless charging pad and
it'll charge so you do have to charge
with usbc
now the real test is
what does it sound like because of this
open ear system this kind of makes it so
that there's no noise cancellation so if
you're a fan of having headphones that
are noise cancelling these are
definitely not something for you these i
feel like are your kind of everyday
walking around
just sort of existing and still being in
the present world i just want my music
to sound good i want to be able to
quickly connect to whatever device i'm
using and i want the microphone to be
clear enough that i can do calls i can
do twitter spaces just work and please
fit in my ear
yeah that's really that's all i've got
to say oh my god i'm gonna go take a
zoom call with these after and see let's
see what they sound like oh
this is
i feel like i'm one of the mods from
boba fett oh my gosh it's like a jewelry
piece like look how well these match my
earrings if only that was a rose gold oh
wow sony hello let's talk about a rose
gold collab can we
whoa
i just had a i had a strange feeling i
just played back the video of me talking
it felt like i was standing right here
and talking to myself in my head i just
had a weird out-of-body experience and
i'm really glad that
you guys were there to experience it
because i'm freaking out okay let's
listen to some music this is so i can
still hear myself talking perfectly fine
and i feel like the thing that kind of
is strange whenever you have those
in-ear headphones that real tight seal
on your ear you can hear yourself
talking inside of your head if you know
what i mean plug your ears and start
talking but with this like it just seems
like the music is playing i can still
hear myself normally as i would normally
be speaking and i'm not distracted by
the music okay let's listen to ed
sheeran bad habits oh yeah this sounds
lovely i can't wait to take my first
zoom call with this now that they're out
i can be like hey you wanna see what
i've got these might be on par with like
my old school airpods and i love those
things with my life like i would put my
life on the line for the original
airpods and i think these
are right up there with it i know this
isn't a sponsored video they sent these
to me to check out i have no obligation
to make a video i was just so excited
about it because there has not been like
a new style
of in-ear
headphones like this i've seen a lot of
earbuds and this is incredibly unique
[Applause]
[Music]
okay here's the test that i want to do
running the running test
so far is happening
you can't tell i'm running and they're
staying in my ears
[Music]
great news
it's a deceivingly
chilly day today
like oh it might be sunny but
it's cold so friends that was just a
first look at the link buds by sony this
is definitely something i think that is
really new and unique and again if you
do want headphones to have noise
cancellation these are 100 not the
headphones for you this is the exact
opposite this is something that allows
you to hear the world around you also
listen to your music oh my breath
i don't even run very far if you guys
haven't already be sure to subscribe i
have a bunch more videos coming out so i
look forward to
seeing you guys
in those are you seeing me okay it's
windy um i'm gonna go bye
[Music]